y pink parece una ciudad fantasma cuando
los soldados ucranianos anunciaron que
lograron recapturar la de las fuerzas
rusas a 30 kilómetros al noreste de kiev
es una puerta de entrada a la capital
del país que el kremlin no ha conseguido
tomar hasta ahora ucrania ha hecho
retroceder a los militares rusos hasta
las afueras de la capital a principios
de esta semana rusia dijo que reduciría
sus operaciones militares alrededor de
kiev y services para el pentágono esto
no es una señal de desescalada rusa
hemos visto en las últimas 24 horas el
reposicionamiento de un pequeño
porcentaje de las tropas y los grupos
tácticos de batallones que rusia había
dispuesto contra que repostar
probablemente rondan en torno al 20 por
ciento de lo que tenían
algunas de esas tropas según nuestras
estimaciones se están reposicionando en
belarús
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski asegura que al tiempo que se
retira rusia está poniendo nuevos
objetivos en la mira
rusia está acumulando fuerzas para
nuevos ataques en el donbass ya y nos
estamos preparando para ellos
antes moscú había dicho que se centraría
en la liberación de la región del
donbass en el este de ucrania
una señal de que el kremlin podría estar
cambiando objetivos más limitados ante
la inesperada resistencia ucraniana en
mariupol en el este de ucrania la crisis
humanitaria se venía agravando con el
paso de los días donde los alimentos
escaseaban y la ciudad estaba sin agua
en electricidad
rusia anunció un alto el fuego para
permitir la evacuación segura de los
civiles mientras que la cruz roja
asegura que ya se están trasladando al
lugar sueño muchísimo en la noche hemos
recibido un mensaje del comité
internacional de la cruz roja
federación rusa confirma su disposición
de permitir el acceso del convoy
humanitario a la ciudad de mariupol a
través de la ciudad de verdiales hemos
enviado 24 buses que están en camino
mariupol a hermoso viaje autobús yo a
pesar de que las autoridades ucranianas
confirmaron que decenas de buses ya
están en camino otros intentos de
ocasión han fracasado